salut à tous cette vidéo est sponsorisée
par norvpn et avant de commencer norvpn
vous remercie de les avoir élus produits
de l'année 2024 norvpn rejoint donc la
liste prestigieuse des lauréa 2024 au
côté de les aon petit
navire l'éponge graten
Flex les serviettes hygiéniques tena
discrit
ultra et la litière pourchat
cstallitepn c'est un outil de
cybersécurité qui ne cesse d'évoluer
chiffrement de vos données protection
antimmenace contre les intrusions et
surveillance du Dark web en cas de fuite
de vos données et en plus récemment
norvpn a conduit un audit indépendant
pour prouver une 4è fois qu'il ne garde
aucun registre des données en ligne de
leur
utilisateur vous savez il y a des
méthodes plus simple pour effacer les
données ah bah oui merci je sais mais
bon la police m'a retient mon fling et
comme toujours norvpn vous permet
d'accéder à tout le contenu exclusif des
plateformes de streaming étrangèr comme
Netflix ou disd plus avec Super Mario
Bros sur le net US ou les gardiens de la
Galaxy 3 sur le Disney US bah bon c'est
pas disponible en France mais je l' remé
l'autre
soir ah wou j'ai trop hâte de regarder
Super Mario de
nouveau utilisez le lien disponible en
description pour une offre
exceptionnelle 4 mois d'abonnement
supplémentaire offert sur un abonnement
de 2 ans si appareils en simultané
disponibles sur iOS Android satisfait ou
remboursé
[Musique]
regarde je t'ai branché un truc super
cool sur ton ordi ça s'appelle un VPN un
VPN qu'est-ce que c'est j'en ai jamais
entendu parler jamais bon en général ça
sert surtout pour garder Netflix dans
les pays étrangers ça sert pas à
grandchose mais celui-là il est très
spécial mais tu as acheté ça où c'est un
petit chinois qui me l'a confié qui fait
des expériences dans son garage il
attrape des mouches avec ses baguettes
HM ça me semble parfaitement crédible
attends je vais te montrer
[Musique]
ok c'est parti je vais disrupter le
faisceau digital Paris à synchroniser l'
pénence c'est ça VPN j'ai toujours cru
que c'était je sais pas un genre de
logiciel alors comment voudrais-tu
rerouter le conducteur sans sa
génératrice numérique expliquemi en la
téléchargeant peut-être
ouais c'est pas fa allez c'est parti
c'est bon ça a marché on est connecté à
une autre dimension là mais non tu vois
bien que ça pas fonctionner quoi tu as
pas vu les éclairs sortir de l'écran
c'est
pété je va mettre le Premium avec ma
carte tant
pis tu aurais pas une carte s'il te
[Musique]
plaît et voilà
mer ça encore
pété tu vois bien que ça a fonctionné
tuas pas vu les éclair sortir de l'écran
là attends tu veux dire qu'on est
vraiment connecté là c'est vraiment le
YouTube d'une autre dimension exactement
et regarde si tu appuies sur F12 tu peux
switcher entre les dimensions
[Musique]
regarde c'est incroyable toutes les
vidéos de mis be sont plagé sur celle d'
vas-y clique sur les tendances prends la
première incroable vasy la deè sal bien
dans cette nouvelle vidéo de chocolat ou
merde 48 alors Julien ce
verdict c'est c'est de la merde
exactement n'oublie pas de crier sur la
sonnette et de cliquer sur le lien en
description de cette vidéo pour obtenir
5 % de réduction à l'achat de minine
rare ouais tu es sûr que c'est une autre
dimension parce que là je vois vraiment
aucune différence non mais attends
regarde C avortement un dollar contre
avortement à 10000 dollars enfin je veux
dire oui bon c'est peut-être un peu
comme une autre dimension mais regarde
des fois les les changements sont un peu
subtiles oh attends c'est bien ce que je
crois vas-y clique dessus cl
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hey on a pris du vin des chips goût vin
et du fromage pour tremper dans le vin
hey salut les filles allez Entz on va
trop s'éclater c'est trop bien et bah
franchement prenez vos aises il y a de
la place partout posez vos affaires trop
cool de nous inviter pour une petite
soirée attend tu rigoles non mais en
plus je nous ai prévu un programme pas
piquer des Nanton ça va être grandiose
euh on pourrait appeler une ambulance
d'abord
alors pour réussir cette soirée je nous
ai prévu des petits jeux mais alors vous
allez
adorer attends tu es pas en train de
tourner un épisode
là non c'est qui ces gens
[Musique]
devant mon père et ses amis tuavais pas
dit qu'il serait pas là cette fois ah
je sais pas j'ai pas bref hein qui nous
est prévu mais alors plein de petits
jeux et des jeux pour filles trop bien
non alors vous allez voir il y a des
jeux de top modèle des jeux de courses
de
quoi tuappelles qui là
uberit il va me falloir plus de 20 les
jeux pour filles c'est pas ça qui manque
il y en a plein mais il y a eu deux
consoles où on en retrouve la plus
grosse concentration c'est sur Nintendo
DS et sur Wii peut-être parce que ce
sont deux consoles très orientées
famille et vous en connaissez forcément
quelques-uns hein des jeux auquels
beaucoup de petites filles ont joué
lea passion Alexandra leaerman les jeux
Barbie
Doom alors beaucoup de ces jeux c'est
surtout pour jouer à la poupée virtuelle
sur ton écran coiffer maquiller habiller
et cetera mais plus cool que de jouer à
la poupée on peut aussi devenir la
poupée ah ouais super le lancement tu es
vraiment un exemple pour toutes les
femmes amerriica Next Top Model dans ce
jeu on incarne donc une jeune mannequin
c'est une adaptation d'une téléréalité
aux États-Unis où su des jeunes filles
qui souhaitent devenir la future
meilleure top modè un jeu qui sera connu
chez nous sous le nom de top model 2005
diffusé sur
[Musique]
M6 pourquoi les personnages discutent
comme s'il faisaient un rap battle salut
ça va tu as fait bon voyage c'était pas
trop long non ça va j'ai dormi et j'ai
manger une salade sur des beau
d'ailleurs c'est qui ce type c'est notre
manager et notre love intere dans le jeu
c'est marqué ici vous avez ce que vous
ressentez pour les personnages neutral
love like hate ah ouais on couche déjà
avec le manager alors que le jeu a même
pas commencé ok ça aurait fini comme ça
de toute façon alors autant gagner du
temps le jeu a donc l'air d'être un j'ai
aucune idée de comment décrire ça un RPG
je sais pas j'ai l'impression d'insulter
Zelda si j'appelle ça RPG mais en même
temps on joue un rôle on a une barre de
faim de santé d'amitié on a des stades
de vêtements on doit discuter avec les
autres filles attends attends 2 secondes
soyons et dememi ah ouais ok c'est
littéralement la première fille que je
rencontre et c'est déjà ma Némésis et
bien voilà c'est donc l'Académie des top
model j'espère que tu te plairas ici je
te présente aux autres candidates
peut-être bonjour [ __ ] bonjour [ __ ]
comme dans son équivalent à la télé il
va donc falloir survivre chaque semaine
une candidate sera éliminée de
l'émission et à la fin il n'en restera
plus qu'une à nous donc de tout faire
pour être celle-ci pour ça tous les
quelques jours un juge viendra et nous
notera sur différents critères de
manière aléatoire style de vêtement
coiffure corps maquillage vous ne savez
jamais sur quoi vous allez êre jugé il
faut donc essayer d'être bonne
[Musique]
partout exhibitioniste je cro bon alors
évidemment on est dans le bon cliché de
la bimbo là ça complimente par devant
avant de chier les missiles dans le dos
ça parle en permanence de maquillage
manucure de coiffure deoing
tu as 8 ans ou quoi non mais attends
parce que des fois au milieu de tous ces
trucs superficiels tu as des moments de
retour à la réalité mais
[Musique]
affreux quoi ouais et c'est pas les
décors qui vont rattraper le jeu c'est
quoi cette statue derrière on dirait un
adulte qui étrangle un enfant j'adore
attendez maintenant je dois aller au
restaurant
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au meilleur restaurant
de la ville qu'est-ce que je vous sers
des nuggets du ketchup on a que ça ah
voilà go to bed et ben sacré journée
hein après s'être levé à 11h45 d'après
le soleil et une dure journée à avoir
mangé un hamburger Micheline retourne se
coucher à 14h20 c'est quel métier de
faire ça la dépression et comme j'ai dit
à la fin de la semaine en plus du
jugement hebdomadaire il faudra aussi
faire un défilé et on a enfin un peu de
gameplay avec d'abord le catwalk
oui c'est un tuto pour marcher ah elle
enchaîne son pied droit et son pied
gauche avec une facilité déconcertante
c'est impressionnant mais comment
fait-elle bon ça va ça a vraiment l'air
débilement facile comme jeu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais je voudrais bien vous y voir
c'est pas pratique avec ses
talons bordel comment peut rater une
marche à ce point là qui marche comme ça
mais même en étant pas manqu on app
[Musique]
barbarale
r c'était bien vraiment
sérieusementouteor
ton défilé et ta marche wou mais super
vous avez pas regardé hein ah non
d'ailleurs sachez que ce jeu est aussi
compatible avec la Wii Balance Board
mais vu le rythme à laquelle vont les
pas pendant le défilé j'ai du mal à voir
comment ça va m'apprendre à être un
véritable mannequin à la fin de chaque
semaine les juges éliminent une
candidate et on passe à la semaine
suivante pour tout recommencer jusqu'à
la fin bon bah ça va le jeu il a l'air
facile
hein ah ouais ça a tourné mal vachement
vite j'ai l'impression ouais j'avoue là
mon personnage passe ses journées à
manger des pizzas en culotte dans la
cuisine la dépression je l'avais dit et
aussi elle se bat contre les autres
candidates en plein centrreville parce
que oui il y a vraiment un gameplay
crépage de chignon mais pas que on va
rendre hommage au jeux il y a quand même
des nouveaux miniux chaque semaine là
par exemple c'est les shooting photos
alors regardez là je prends des
classique petite photos de pique-nique
entre tradition et
modernité quoi tu aimes pas manger des
riettes en culotte toi moi je fais ça
tous les samedis il est où le piquenique
il est là on le voit pas parce que c'est
en dessous de du bah c'est le ouais h
bref c'est la fête sans la barbe papa le
r des enfants voilà on s'amuse là nous
sommes à Dubaï Dubaï il fait chaud c'est
la chaleur les sablees et là te voilà s
la lune attention oh là là l'oxygène
l'étouffage arrivve à grandp elle est
sympa ta pyjama parti où il y a que toi
qui joue tu veux pas qu'on te masse les
épauul aussi pendant que tu es la seule
à t'amuser c'est une vraie question bah
ouais elle a raison on pourrait
peut-être se faire un truc à plusieurs
un petit jeu de course grave on pourrait
faire un Mario Kart d'une autre
dimension j'ai jamais compris pourquoi
ce jeu s'appelait comme ça d'ailleurs
ouais mais non les filles c'est une
soirée pour filles on va pas jouer à
Mario carte par contre on peut carrément
jouer à action girl
tracing non mais c'est exactement comme
Mario Kart hein allez on choisit la
difficulté la vitesse de la course ils
se sont même pas embêté à changer les
chiffres par rapport à Mario Kart et on
commence par choisir son personnage et
dites pourquoi on dirait que les
personnages du jeu ont été dessinés par
une enfant de 5 ans et j'ai 6
ans pardon bon alors le jeu est
clairement un clone de Mario Kart he il
y a des items à ramasser pour lancer sur
ses opposants des flèches jaunes qui
vont booster la vitesse des objets à
ramasser qui te permettent d'accélérer
peu à peu exactement comme les pièces de
Mario Kart bah pourquoi on joue pas
plutôt à Mario Kart alors parce que
Mario Kart ça coûte 60 balles che
capitaliste et je le dis directement ce
jeu est connu comme étant un des pires
jeux de coursees de la Wii que ce soit
visuellement ou au niveau du level
design c'est horrible le décor ce qu'
faond régulièrement avec la route non
mais c'est quoi cette porte fermée là
quoi un mur une porte c'est impossible
de deviner et c'est [ __ ] de virage en
angle droit partout là vous l'avez voyez
le virage vous vous l'avez vu vous le
virage hein c'est bien gentil de mettre
des panneaux du cul pour rraper vos
échecs mais j'aimerais plutôt voir le
virage dans le jeu en fait comprenez que
dans Mario Kart les virages en angle
droit mur sont très rares ils s'arrange
toujours pour avoir des courbes de cette
manière même quand tu te prends un mur
tu n'es pas à l'arrêt tu frottes le bord
certes ça te ralentit mais tu continues
d'avancer et ça te donne le temps de te
replacer sur la route mais ici non
bordel c'est le tout début de la course
et il y a un cul de sac je suis bloqué
dans un cul de sac pourquoi mettre un
[ __ ] de cul de sac dans un jeu de
course pourquoi mettre des items dans un
cul de sac à part pour vouloir me
tromper mais regardez cet échec moi ma
caméra a disparu dans les textures et
les trois autres conduisent comme Stev W
ur je sais que c'est dur à comprendre
sans la manette en main mais croyez-moi
les bagnoles ont vraiment la maniabilité
d'une boule de bouline sur une piste en
merde et pourquoi ce jeu est moins bon
que M&M's Racing sérieusement comment
ils ont pu faire un jeu pourfille moins
bon qu'un jeu avec des poules en
chocolat qui parle qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait pour mériter ça fallait pas manger
la pomme mais [ __ ] oui tout ça c'est à
cause de cette [ __ ] d'Ève et oh mon
dieu les contrôles du jeu ça me fait
péter les plombs tourne
le con de ta chatte tourne pourquoi tout
est si dur chaque virage te donne envie
de te planter la WI mode dans les yeux
moi c'est simple j'y vais en marche
arrière comme ça c'est plus facile mais
moi c'est même pas les virages j'arrive
pas à aller droit même ça c'est trop dur
parce que oui il faut le dire mais le
jeu ne se joue qu'avec le gyroscope de
la WOT il y a pas le choix c'est
impossible d'y jouer avec les croix
directionnelles ah mais merde pourquoi
le jeu nous donne l'impression qu'on
sait pas conduire là il essaie de nous
envoyer un message ou quoi et les items
ils servent à quoi au jeu B moi j'ai
ramassé un miroir et alors ah oui il y a
ça aussi he c'est impossible de définir
à quoi servent les items le miroir serra
je sais même pas ça renvoie pas les
attaques ça protège pas les coups le
téléphone tire des boules de feu mais
l'autre téléphone tire aussi des boules
de feu vous pouviez pas plutôt mettre un
dessin de bouclier ou un dessin de boule
de feu fallait forcément mettre des
papillons et des arcorciels et
d'ailleurs comment on utilise les items
faut secouer la manette super pratique
dans un jeu qui se joue au gyroscope
alors juste par contre petite subtilité
sur cette voiture pour cllaxonner il
faut
faire alors l'arrière de la boîte dit le
seul jeu de course conçu par des filles
pour des filles les action girls sont là
alors prends ta trousse à maquillage
c'est un jeu fait par des mecs non ouais
complètement définitivement fait par des
mecs alors quand on regarde les crédits
du jeu sur la version PS2 on voit que
ceci mentionne beaucoup de femmes sauf
qu'en fait c'est juste des mecs qui ont
féminisé leur nom Carle White est cité
sous le nom de Carla white Ran en r
Adrian Fox en Adriana Foxy theoman en
Theo woman attends c'est moi qui se fout
de notre gueule là bon après si tu veux
voir autre chose il y a un monde JDG une
nendive ça
t'intéresse
regarde bon après ça fait 15 ans qu'ils
font ça donc évidemment ils ont plus la
la fraîcheur des débuts tu vois mais
mais si tu veux je peux te mettre une
dimension où JDG est un légume mais on
vient pas de le voir
[Musique]
hop ok on va peut-être remettre la vidéo
d'avant allez les filles c'est l'heure
de la pyjama partie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez vas-y ça casse les couilles là on
va passer la
cinématique charm Girls Club pyjama
party parye game pour filles de la Wii
ambiance très girly maquillage fête et
shopping du début des années 2000 on est
vraiment dans la définition du jeu qui
en fait trop pour les filles il y a des
petites étoiles qui brillent pour faire
les transitions des petites étoiles dans
le menu la souris c'est aussi une petite
étoiles le jeu est donc un party game
assez classique qui se joue à 4 mais
peut monter jusqu'à h joueurs et on
commence d'abord en choisissant le nom
de la fête et j'ai choisi la fête à la
saucisse
e vous avez pas l'impression parfois que
toutes nos lignes de dialogue ont été
écrites par des hommes ah ça casserait
les couilles on choisit le nombre de
tours les personnages qu'on va jouer
diva super cops adorable fille cool
beauté glamour c'est quand même super
réducteur de no ok toi tu seras
casseecouille
dépressive vendu on sélectionne le
curseur évidemment à base d'étoile de
diamants et de petits papillons et c'est
parti chacun son tour on va pouvoir
lancer la roue qui va sélectionner les
mini jeux avec à chaque fois des petits
conseils pendant les écrans de
chargement les pyjamas parties existent
depuis la nuit des temps c'est vrai ça
Bata j'ai
[Musique]
gagné et bien bonjour je suis diplômé en
préhistoire et cette affirmation est
vraie le pyjama fut créé après la
première pyjama partie où tout le monde
était complètement à poil c'était très
gênant leur père entra alors dans la
grotte et s'esclama plus jamais puis
avec le temps et la déformation des
langues indo-européennes plus jamais
devint pyjama plus jamais plus
Jama
pyjama pyjama
tu peux aller fermer la porte s'il te
plaît bon après en vrai les jeux sont
pas spécialement mauvais c'est un party
game tout à fait classique c'est juste
que l'emballage est un énorme cliché
girly de paillett et d' ah j'avais
oublié ce truc j'adorais j'en avais
plein quand j'étais pardon bref on
retrouve tout le panel des trucs qu'on
ne fait jamais en soirée pyjama parce
que ce serait trop chiant à ranger on
saute sur le lit on fait des gâteaux on
met de la laque dans les cheveux on
danse sur le dance floor d'ailleurs
parfois pendant les épreuves la wimot
essaie de nous encourager avec la voix
de la télécommande bravo super mais le
son est tellement de mauvaise qualité
qu'on a l'impression qu'il y a un robot
excité qui nous parle Bou ton
cul on peut changer de jeu s'il vous
plaît ah allez nouveau jeu ah la
classique bataille d'oreiller d'ailleurs
un détail chaque fois que la roue
s'arrête tout le monde peut agiter sa W
pour la faire avancer davantage alors
c'est rigolo de minutes mais bon la roue
elle tombe jamais sur le bon résultat au
final alors M mou à la fête tout le
monde se lève et change de place
ou le jeu est classique hein pareil les
quatre filles vont sortir par
intermittence d'une cachette il faut
viser les autres et juste faire
attention à ne pas se viser
soi-même attendez une seconde si on est
toutes là qui nous tire dessus
d'ailleurs chaque miniu réussi vous
permettra de récupérer des charms ou
grriis gris en anglais c'est des genres
de petits bijoux on a des chaussures de
mode du rouge à lèvres des sacs à main
et ça sert à
quoi c'est à moi de lancer la roue
allez oh cool un quiz anecdote perso
Sarah dépense tout son argent en bandeau
et bracelet et toi qu'achètes-tu avec
ton argent de poche moi rien parce que
je suis pauvre ah oui pas mal les quiz
quelles activités pratiquaient déjà les
êtres humains il y a 5000 ans parler au
téléphone les défilés de mode l'envoi de
SMS ou la danse concentrez-vous les
filles d'ailleurs à propos des miniux il
y en a qui relève de la torture quand
même he genre faire une NAT à 4at en
mode compétitif
là euh c'est moi ou plus on avance dans
la soirée pyjama plus ça part en couille
c'est quoi ça on récupère des lucioles
en faisant du vélo dans la r elles
écrasent des insectes avec leurs mains
mais c'est dégueulasse et pourquoi elles
rigolent tout le temps comme ça elles
sont en route vers leur dealer attends
et maintenant c'est quoi là on fait des
courses illégales en scooter dans les
rues du quartier mais regardez faut
accélérer puis piler au dernier moment
il y a des jouets pour enfants sur les
trottoirs c'est pas hyper dangereux ça
la nuit en plus tout le monde dort et
ben là ça devient intéressant activité
de fête tout le monde se lève et saute
sur un pied allez on fait tout ça enfin
sauf toi Sar du coup oh non mais c'est
pas grave je le prends pas
mal attendez comment elle va repartir
sans ascenseur bon bah elle va gérer
hein bon et ben moi je vais y aller hein
il est déjà 20h30 et et je dois rentrer
chez moi
pour regarder mon
mur OK et ben on va conclure la notion
de jeu pour fille elle a pas vraiment de
sens je veux dire on parle pas de jeu
pour garçon c'est un peu un truc par
défaut alors pourquoi est-ce que la
notion de jeu pour filles existerait ben
ça existe enfin ça existé parce que
maintenant ça a presque disparu parce
qu'au début du jeu vidéo on a longtemps
considéré une fille qui jouait comme une
licorne un phénomène tellement rare
qu'il fallait forcément qu'elle ait sa
catégorie à part avec des paillettes et
des poneys il y a certes des jeux qui
sont sont statistiquement plus joué par
des filles Just Dance par exemple ou les
Sims mais pourtant c'est des jeux pour
tous et on est plus dans les années 80
où il y avait peu de joueus et
maintenant les filles jouent à tout he
d'ailleurs messieurs il y a de fortes
chances que vous soyez déjà fait casser
la gueule par une meuf en pyjama en
jouant un multi sur callof OK stop stop
ça suffit j'ai rien dit jusque là mais
vraiment cette dimension elle a aucun
[ __ ] de sens ah bon parce que je
pensais quand même ça fonction non mais
tuas pasas c'est lunettes il y a pas de
verre dans ses lunettes tu as pas vu
c'est débile d'accord ok bon attends
j'ai une meilleure idée si tu
m'autorises est-ce qu' peux aller voir
une dimension que je voulais voir depuis
très longtemps tu es sûr de toi
[Musique]
j'avoue bonne idée ben vas-y
any you W as long as all
right and we don't need the drama we
find on run away with me
tonightuse it feels like I'm dreaming
when I'm wing up next to you and my
world heart
Ising because next to you let's find
something better to on we can do
anything we want to and I can't help the
feel that I when next to you
[Musique]